foreign
Minister has delayed the announcement of
its fiscal statement from next Monday to
November the 17th the extra three weeks
will be used to reconsider where
spending will be cut to fill that black
hole in the government's finances
estimates vary but somewhere between 30
and 40 billion pounds now one option
that appears to be back on the table is
putting up pensions by less than the
rate of inflation in line with wages
instead to discuss that and much much
more and we're joined once again on the
program at binder deems are how it this
time at conservative party chairman so
congratulations on the new job let us
start with the fiscal statement being
delayed there was a real needs not that
long ago to steady the markets which was
why it was brought forward from November
to the 31st of October why then are we
are we seeing this delay well I think
because the uh Chancellor and the Prime
Minister quite rightly you've got a new
cabinet you secretary's estate getting
familiar with their departments
um felt that having an Autumn statement
uh on the 17th of November will give
everyone around the table a bit more
time to be able to look carefully
there's not going to be any easy
decisions I can tell you because I've
been there myself been Secretary of
Education of course I was Chancellor for
a short period of time at the summer and
then as Chancellor duchy of Lancaster
the cabinet office the sort of the
operation side of government but what
the Prime Minister wanted to do is make
sure that we you know Circle back and
look at everything closely the important
thing to remember is as he said
yesterday he'll always be on the side
and he mentioned pensioners of those
most vulnerable in our side here's the
chancellor that delivered the 1200 pound
additional help for the 8 million most
vulnerable households so we'll look at
all of that in the round and the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt will then make
that Autumn statement on the 17th of
November but this is undoubtedly going
to be a prime minister if he was going
to have to deliver a significant cuts to
public spending isn't he he said that
yes there's not going to be any ease
decisions you have to step back a second
and think where we are today we have war
on our continent this is a major war we
absolutely like it since the second
world war Putin is using energy as a
weapon not just we saw when I was in the
treasury where gas prices were spiking
so uh suddenly that many businesses
viable businesses were worried about
being put out of business the energy uh
intervention we made has made a
difference but actually he's using it if
you look at what's happening with food
costs because energy then reflects into
food prices so the chancellor and the
Prime Minister are determined that we
send a very clear message to the markets
that we are financially responsible
completely and we have an energy plan to
to be to deliver that energy security
for this country in the medium term and
all of us understand the necessity to
reassure the markets that's because of
what let's trust and quasiquiteng did
and look I understand that you are not
the chancellor you are not in a position
to to kind of perhaps be specific on on
the the intimate detail of what is going
to be announced on the 17th of November
but the triple lock on pensions I mean
your colleague Maria Caulfield put it
puts it like this when the government
doesn't confirm one way or another
speculation amounts vacuums are created
people start to worry I've got
pensioners who are worried can you tell
us this morning what will be happening
with the triple law so I think it would
be unwise of me to preempt the Autumn
statement uh I this government is about
responsibility and sustainability what I
would say to pensioners watching this
morning is both uh the Prime Minister
and the chancellor are very much aware
and I'm going to State the obvious is
pensioners are uniquely unable to work
to uh you know and add to their income
it should be tied to inflation rather
than wages so again it's so right in a
position to answer that question it's
irresponsible to preempt an Autumn
statement with an Autumn statement you
know we governments wait until the
chance has done the work to be able to
make those announcements in the
appropriate and proper way we we aren't
expecting shell you know massive uh
petrochem giant to announce its profits
in the next few minutes and it's
expected they will they will run into
the multiple billion 60 billion was an
estimate so this morning somewhere um at
a time like this when such difficult
decisions as you've just conceded there
will have to be cuts to Public Services
made isn't no the time to look again at
the windfall tax expanding its scope
making it broader and using some of that
money to plug the whole that we all know
exist in part because of what
quasiquating and Liz trust did so I'm
glad you mentioned
um the windfall textbook there is
already a windfall tax on these energy
producers
and of course that's producing about
five billion pounds of additional income
into the uh Treasury and of course we
went further because what quasi did
quite rightly was look at those who
generate energy who were not changing
anything in their model Renewables are
nuclear but whose price was pegged to
gas price we're paying a much higher
price for Energy giving away yes 9.5
billion don't you think we could maybe
take some of that off shell and use it
to pay nurses a bit more money I mean
those are the calculations that you have
to make look if you can't commit to
expanding the windfall tax I know that's
a job to the chancellor but just
personally don't you think there's an
argument for it well as I said we
already have a windfall tax the
important thing actually is to make sure
those companies are investing in gas
assets in the North Sea this year we've
seen a 26 increase in our gas output
that's a good thing because we're less
reliant on Putin's gas we have to well
no hold on a second we have to we have
to make sure that those companies will
be incentivized to investor what Rishi
has done in the past if you remember is
incentivize for example the BT and
others too invest in Broadband the
question of whether or not by using your
taxes we aren't going to move on but
just just just finally on all of this
and before we move on to the kind of the
internal problems in the conservative
party
um James cleverley foreign Secretary of
course sitting where you were yesterday
and we got onto the issue of Qatar and
the World Cup that is taking place there
I just want to get your reviews has his
his words yesterday were to football
fans particularly to gay football fans
to be respectful of the host nation to
show a little bit of of flex and
compromise I mean was the foreign
secretary telling people to dial down
the gay if they want to go to the World
Cup no he wasn't well absolutely not so
so what he was saying is the policies of
the government are not our policies uh
nor would we condone them in fact we use
our relationship uh to make sure that
every opportunity we get to share our
values to share how we behave in this
country with countries like Qatar and
others um but they they have their own
um culture and ways and have come to
um where they are at from a from a
different Journey it's any surprise that
there aren't more out gay footballers
when FIFA Awards the World Cup to Qatar
well look the World Cup is in Qatar I
think it's important as I said to always
what at every opportunity and I was
Vector very recently the responsible for
equalities in this country
um to make the point that you know these
values are Universal they're important
values and other countries need to go on
a journey as well should any future
World Cup be held in a country where gay
people cannot walk down that street
holding the hands for goodness sake as I
said the policies of of countries like
Qatar not heart policies nor do we
condone them uh and I think that's the
message I want to send to anybody uh
watching this program today
um let's talk about the Home Secretary
we have to spend a bit of time on this
we heard from from Jake Berry yesterday
he characterized the situation as as
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code is that accurate so the Prime
Minister has looked at this
um the Home Secretary herself if you
recall uh in her letter said I made a
mistake I'm not going to deny that or
shirk away from it I will resign she
resigned quite rightly the new prime
minister dealt with this yesterday
looked at it and he felt that she and as
I would feel she has allowed a second
chance so so there weren't multiple
breaches of the ministerial so the use
of the personal email address the
leaking of sensitive government
information uh sending it to the wrong
email address I mean that that in and of
itself are multiple breaches but but
again we will ask the same questions
that were asked in the House of Commons
yesterday did officials raise concerns
about swella Braverman did the cabinet
secretary warn against her reappointment
so officials raised concerns and raise
points with uh secretary state with
ministers all the time and I think they
should be allowed to do that
um and and having you know discussions
on air about what officials advice uh
ministers I think would be unhealthy are
for the way we we run our country
because they feel free they can do that
without being quoted a public secretary
there is a security Dimension here I
mean does she have full security
clearance the the homes actually has
full security clearance of course but
what I'm really trying to say to you is
she didn't you know try and hide away or
try and brush this under the carpet
reports about the fact that Richie soon
I claimed that yesterday in the House of
Commons it wasn't it wasn't the Home
Secretary who reported admitted it was
identified and she got sacked for he
admitted her mistake once she could
resigned she resigned and she apologized
and actually people in my view I hope
you think you agree with me are allowed
a second chance
yes I understand the opportunity for
Redemption but when you're the Home
Secretary dealing with sensitive
security documents I'd say that possibly
you need to spend a bit more time in the
wilderness than six days after you get
sat for a security breach I mean it's
been dressed up as if this is some kind
of technical breach let's examine
exactly what she did she leaked
immigration policy and data to a fellow
traveler in terms of migration policy
using a private email address I mean
that isn't just a breach of the
ministerial code that is how undermining
the government and for whom she served
she as I said she admitted her mistake
she resigned a new prime minister came
in looked at the information and decided
that he wants to give her a second
chance I think that's a the right
decision it's the right thing you just
said Redemption is a good thing politics
now uh you know it has been compressed
in terms of timelines because of the
change we've just had and what so if
it's happened a month from now or two
months from now does this government
take people for fools it is clear that
she was only reappointed because Rishi
sunak needed to reach out to the right
of the party I mean it's not as if
soella bravaman is the intellectual
Paradise of the conservative movement
that's you're now personalizing being
very rude about a particular policy I
think as well is very capable uh it's
unfair for you to say that so I would
just ask you to reflect on that
she is incredibly capable to fill the
post of Home Secretary other than the
person who got sacked from it six days
ago but don't you understand that there
is a degree of frustration that people
have that there is this kind of wash
rinse repeat cycle in government at the
moment that someone messes up royally
they apologize and then they act as if
the apology sometimes somehow makes
everything you know peachy again wait
wait wait a second wait a second you
should apologize she resigned she didn't
just apologize keep me on she resigned
and apologized and a new promise came in
and looked at the information decided to
give her a second this is the first time
I've been here Gavin Williamson now back
in cabinet pretty Patel sat from
International Sac from International
Development back into the home office
Chris pincher you could equally argument
Boris Johnson got sacked by the party a
handful of weeks ago and at the weekend
you were campaigning for him let me tell
you why because I called him Boris
Johnson two point North I didn't want to
see
um or give the perception to the country
or to our membership that we are somehow
conspiring to keep the man who delivered
a mandate for all of us because we all
own that mandate uh being kept off the
ballot it had to come from him now I'm
going to say something to you if it does
Boris one point naught he'll probably
kept going because he had the numbers
Boris 2.0 decided to put country and
party ahead of self-interest and step
aside and support Richie sunac I'm very
proud of that that's a good thing we've
come together as a party as a family
around that table look around that
cabinet table as a Cabinet of all the
talents that's a good thing and it
should be celebrated and you may
disagree with me but I think people are
allowed a second chance and I think the
Privacy did the right thing to give
swella that second chance I will not
again though that you can see that there
were probably multiple breaches of the
ministerial court and indeed that
probably officials advised against her
reappointment as Home Secretary but
there is a revolving door policy going
on in government at the moment
particularly in senior posts I mean
here's a question and you and I we have
spoken an awful lot over the past few
years particularly when you were
vaccines Minister we've all I've always
appreciated your candor during some of
those interviews can you tell me how
many jobs you have had in government
since 2019 yes I can I mean I'm very
proud so I've been the business
secretary business Minister I've never
made business secretary so vaccine
Minister and I'm very proud of what we
delivered on vaccines I was Secretary of
State for Education where I we did
skills schools families and I know the
Secretary of State for Education will
continue that Journey on skills name
jobs you've had nine jobs in government
since 2019 now some of those were held
concurrently yeah I will concede yes but
at the same time doesn't that
demonstrate why this government has a
real problem getting to grips with
problems as they arise plotting policy
that lasts longer than three weeks let
alone three years I mean someone like
you who has been through nine ministers
jobs Gavin Robinson back and back in
government to Ella Bradman this is not a
government that looks as if it is
performing surely so you mentioned Gavin
Williamson and I think
um I've said this on Sky actually some
time back
um Kevin Williamson did more to drive
the skills agenda t levels where you
know new and Incredibly exciting runways
for young people to get a career to get
onto that career ladder he did a
tremendous job on skills so I think keep
attacking people he's been he's been out
of government in the wilderness you're
I'll tell you where I'm going to agree
with you you're right we've had
instability we've made mistakes
Richardson said I'm going to correct
those mistakes you're going to see from
sunac a person who is reflective who's
on top of the detail who's about
sustainability of the economy and having
a plan a plan to deliver for this
country when we have war on our
continent we will see how long that
lasts and Mr zawi it is always great to
have you in the studio so I do
appreciate your time thank you let's
have a quick look at the papers though
and where should we start with some of
the eye today it reports uh that Rishi
tsunite could be set to make
far-reaching spending cuts next month
after ripping up his predecessor Liz
trussy's economic plans
uh well with the fracking ban reinstated
doubts again about the pensions triple
up the guardian says the trust Legacy
has been rejected
but the express asks do you really want
to scrap the triple pension lock again
foreign
tax Rises could again be on the cards
the financial times says the three-week
delay to next Monday's fiscal statement
by the chance that we'll give him
breathing space to work out how best to
balance the books in the face of the
economic crisis
uh well of course you've heard me
mention it whilst we were talking to Mr
zahawi the oil giant shell has published
its third quarter financially results
our politics and business correspondent
Amanda Akins joins us now on the program
Amanda what are we learning
well in the past quarter shell made
bumper profits of 9.5 billion dollars
now that is slightly less than during
their record last quarter when that
figure was 11.5 billion dollars but
obviously still a huge amount the
company says the drop is down to a
weaker natural gas trading and a
reduction in oil refining margins but
it's still massively up on the same
quarter this time last year when it was
4.1 billion a real indication of the
impact on energy markets of Russians
Russia's invasion of Ukraine now these
huge sums of money flowing into the oil
and gas companies will surely reignite
calls for an expansion of the windfall
tax in May uh this year the current
prime minister then Chancellor announced
a 25 windfall tax on the excess profits
made by these companies on top of the 40
uh tax they were already paying
um which was estimated would bring in
around 5 billion pounds a year but a lot
of it could be offset through a tax
relief scheme of companies invested in
new extraction projects opposition
parties have been calling for that
windfall tax to be massively expanded uh
labor believe if they did so and scrap
the tax release scheme they could bring
in 8 billion pounds to help pay for the
energy price cap
Liz truss always argued that this would
send out the wrong message and
discourage companies from investing in
the UK although interestingly a few
weeks ago her Administration did
announce a cap on the profits made by
renewable energy companies which labor
described as a kind of windfall tax and
interestingly a few weeks ago the
outgoing chief executive of shell said
it was inevitable that the companies
would be facing more of a windfall tax
and he said governments should be taxing
these companies more to help protect the
poorest in society from the impact of
these huge bills all of the this 9.5
billion pounds bumper a billion dollars
sorry bumper profits adding to the
pressure on the chancellor and the Prime
Minister ahead of that Autumn statement
in November the 17th
Amanda many thanks and of course nadines
are we just on the program and go at
refusing to be drawn in the possibility
of a perhaps an extension to the
windfall tax I'd say watch this space
but still to come on the program today
at libert Shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy will be on the sofa at 8 o'clock
as demonstrators in Iran continue to
protest the death of Massachusetts
probably speaking to the activist
Nazarene parvats who alleges that she
was systematically tortured and serving
eight years in the country's prison
system
and that's the wrong British Legion
launches its annual poppy appeal I'll be
speaking to an RAF veteran who served in
Afghanistan about how the charity helped
support her as she returned to civilian
life
let's turn to Ukraine now and the
offensive to retake the city of Carson
from Russia Ukraine's defense minister
has admitted the counter-offensive is
proving difficult because of poor
weather and the nature of the terrain
well the city of Carson itself is
certainly strategically important to
both Russia and Ukraine the reason its
position on the denipral river and its
proximity to the annexed of course
Crimea our team entered one of the
surrounding Villages villaica Alexander
Alexander rifkad now dealing with the
aftermath of Russian occupation from
their Skies International correspondent
John Sparks reports
as the Russians Retreat from communities
in her song residents are left with
reminders of their stay
a swathe of Destruction in towns and
Villages like valleca alexandrithika
it can be difficult to take it all in
this quiet community spent months on the
front line
and the fire chief suggested we
investigate the local school
he led us into an underground room and
we could see it had been used by the
Russians
we saw lewd graffiti and the letter Z
the symbol of Russia's war in Ukraine
along with the date the Russians took
over this town 2602
fire chief velodimir beckoned us into
the gloom and we realized it was more
than just a bomb shelter but look this
community school had been turned into a
military base
foreign
how many soldiers
live down here do you think
you think at least 200
.
this Subterranean Labyrinth had been
dressed in soft Furnishings the
occupants seemingly planning to stay
it's very strange there are a dozen
rooms down here maybe more and they've
all been decorated with this tent-like
effect
the soldiers have been trying to make it
look like home I think
there were multiple kitchens and places
to eat
and some items look surprisingly
luxurious we found perfumes and silk
bedding
members of this Garrison made a swift
departure but some have threatened to
return
it's interesting this this message left
on the wall down here says soon
will return soon we'll come back
sinister
the war was fought on the upper three
floors in a school that had been turned
into a fortress
the classrooms were sandbagged with
occasional slits so the Russians could
fire their weapons
the school library deployed as a blast
wall
and there were putanesque views scrolled
on the walls come and take a look at
this this is the English language room
and see what they've done to the map of
Great Britain the UK and Ireland had
been covered with a zed Plus rossia or
Russia at the bottom
it's sad isn't it I mean the school's
been trashed
um
but it will cost hundreds of billions of
pounds to rebuild this country and the
conflict goes on
most residents fled before the Russian
occupation but those who stayed have
been marked by it Tatiana told us the
soldiers were only boys
did you feel sorry for them
foreign
this unpopular War may have come to a
close in this town at least
but the battle to the south for the city
of Herson will be Savage
joy in Liberation must be balanced with
the pain
John Sparks Sky News in valleca
alexandrefka
time for a quick look at some of the
day's other headlines now and a
parliamentary inquiry has warned that
Britain's National Security is at risk
because of a failure to prepare for the
increasing risks of extreme weather due
to climate change the joint committee on
the National Security strategy said it
was a severe dead election of Duty that
no Minister was prepared to take
responsibility for ensuring vital power
transport and Communications networks
remaining resilient
months of political turmoil at
Westminster could cost the taxpayer up
to 726
000 pounds in Severance payments
analysis by Sky News has found that
nearly all of the 79 ministers and whips
who were sacked or resigned so far this
year are eligible for the payments
averaging more than ten thousand pounds
schools which ban Afro hairstyles
without making exceptions on racial
grants are likely to be acting
unlawfully the equality and Human Rights
Commission has issued new guidance
saying that school policies shouldn't
unfairly single out children because
they have afro here
the Northern Ireland assembly has been
recalled in a last ditch effort to form
a devolved government before tonight's
midnight deadline six months after the
storm until action the dup is refusing
to restore power sharing with Sinn Fein
demanding changes to the brexit protocol
and with no sign of breakthrough the
Northern Ireland secretary Chris Heaton
Harris is poised to call a second
election Before Christmas our senior
Ireland correspondent David Blevins has
been talking to younger voters
struggling to break free from the same
old politics they represent a new
generation of Voters Callum Mark and
Sophie work with young people from lower
income families and of more pressing
concerns than the brexit protocol the
reality is paying your bills is harder
now than actually discussing the
protocol I don't really care about the
protocol anymore I'm more concerned
about the people in the community that
can't afford their oil bill they can't
you know afford their food prices have
went through the roof and I'm seeing it
through school and just in everyday life
like in school I'm paying nearly 10
pounds for a meal and that's just to
feed myself for one day
it's six months since Shin Fan's
historic Victory winning the most seats
at Stormont Michelle O'Neal on course to
become the first nationalist to hold the
office of first Minister but the dup
won't restore power sharing unless the
brexit Border in the Irish sea is
scrapped so Northern Ireland faces
another election much to the frustration
of these young voters young people want
to go on a holiday young people want to
be able to afford to get a house young
people want to be able to grow up and
get married young people want a society
that works rather than what flags flying
on the Lamppost they say that isn't like
the main issue right now and whether
you're British or Irish if you can't
afford these things what's the use in in
either really
Northern Ireland has the lowest
disposable income in the UK and the
highest energy prices there's little
appetite for a rerun of the pole at a
cost of six and a half million pounds if
there's another election it will
illustrate two things the damage brexit
and the resulting protocol has done to
power sharing in Northern Ireland and
the widening Gulf between the people and
the politics because many voters are
more concerned about how they heat the
house and put food on the table than
they are about where Northern Ireland's
political future lies
if there's no power and the corridors at
Stormont there's no hope for people when
they need it most and that could signal
the end of Good Friday agreement
politics David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast
welcome back quick reminder as to our
top stories this hour and Rishi sunak is
facing pressure to protect the triple
lock on pensions after Daniel Street
refused to confirm whether or not
they'll rise in life of inflation
and in the last hour the oil giant shell
has posted quarterly profits of 9.5
billion dollars
on this program the conservative party
chairman defended the Home Secretary
swell apartment for breaking the
ministerial Court saying she deserved a
second chance
uh well let's bring a little more on
that story the conservative party
chairman the new conservative party
chairman Nadeem zahawi told the program
that the Home Secretary does have full
security clearance despite resigning
Just A Week Ago over a security breach
she was of course reappointed by Rishi
sunak
the Prime Minister has looked at this
the Home Secretary herself if you recall
uh in her letter said I made a mistake
I'm not going to deny that or shirk away
from it I will resign she resigned quite
rightly the new prime minister dealt
with this yesterday looked at it and he
felt that she and as I would feel she is
allowed a second chance so so there were
multiple breaches of the ministerial
called that so the use of the personal
email address the leaking of sensitive
government information uh sending it to
the wrong evil just I mean that that in
and of itself are multiple breaches but
but again we will ask the same questions
that were asked in the House of Commons
yesterday did officials raise concerns
about swella Braverman did the cabinet
secretary warn against her reappointment
so officials raised concerns and raise
points with uh secretary state with
ministers all the time and I think they
should be allowed to do that
um and and having you know discussions
on air about what officials advice uh
ministers I think would be unhealthy for
our for the way we we run our country
because feel free they can do that
without being quoted
secretary there is a security Dimension
here I mean does she have full security
clearance the homes actually has full
security clearance of course but what
I'm really trying to say to you is she
didn't you know try and hide away or try
and brush something
I claimed that yesterday in the House of
Commons it wasn't it wasn't the Home
Secretary who reported admitted has
identified and she got sacked before he
admitted her mistake why don't she could
resigned she resigned and she apologized
and actually people in my view I hope
you agree with me are allowed a second
chance
uh let's bring in our political
correspondent Ali Fortress good morning
Ali look we can leave aside the
semantics of sacking or resigning but it
does still feel that the soil a problem
and story has a bit to run particularly
because there are some significant
questions still to be answered about
what was advised and who knew what and
when yeah I think the big question is
from from Beth root be our place where
does the sources it looks like the prime
minister's warned by the cabinet
secretary about
um swella braveman concerns were raised
on that this morning Nadine zahari said
to you look concerns are often raised by
civil servants that's the way things
work it's best he doesn't talk about
that on TV but clearly I think this is
something that labor are going in hard
on and clearly I think it's something
that people are probably on the outside
quite surprised by the fact that six
days since someone was sacked for
breaking the ministerial code they're
back in the job this is someone that
obviously her endorsing Rishi night was
a big moment for him over the weekend
she has massive sway on the right of the
party at the moment there is no sign at
all that she is going anywhere I think
it would be we're not there yet it would
be a big problem for him if she was on
the back bench as if she went with a
fight
um so he is trying to hold on to his
home secretary labor calling for invest
an investigation they spent a lot of
prime minister's questions yes today
talking about a grubby deal that they
allege happened
saying that this is a prime minister who
said he's all about integrity but
actually nothing's changed I think it is
potentially very damaging because Rishi
sunak is trying to paint himself as
someone who's different from his two
predecessors someone who can be trusted
someone who can level with people and if
these questions continue to loom over
him that could be very difficult
certainly could Ali much more from you
throughout the program for no thanks
very much indeed but let's take you back
to that breaking news we had a little
earlier this hour shell announcing its
third quarter profits of 9.5 billion
dollars but while the big energy
companies enjoy huge profits everyone
else is struggling with Rising bills and
there are growing concerns about whether
or not the lights will stay on this
winter joining us on the program uh
Chris Christina rabbit energy analyst
and the chief executive of the renewable
energy platform papaya uh Christina
lovely to have you on the program this
morning
um first and foremost are you in any way
shocked by the level of profit that
shell continues to enjoy uh at this kind
of this time at least
um I think
um seeing where the markets are right
now on the where they have been for the
last 18 months
um in no way shocked um of how much
profit uh they've made this quarter so
no
and but aren't we in essence aren't
large parts of the world in Hawk to the
oil and energy Industries at least until
fossil fuels begin to appear to be royal
to be to be running out there seems to
be so much of our industry power
generation and so on that is sort of
like that despite the push to renewals
there will always be a sizable chunk of
the world that still relies on the
consumption of these fossil fuels so I
think um that's one thing that
um I'm all parties either on the
renewable side or on the fossil fuel
side
um need to know that right now we need
um Everybody in the game to uh to reduce
the bills to create
um a stable
um you know energy uh consumption and uh
Supply in in the country and um it's um
as much as
um it's sort of scary to see how big of
a profits are being made by certain
companies
um also um it's important to understand
that we have to be realistic
um about how we're going to provide the
energy security
um and fossil fuels still play a very
big part in providing that um and
unfortunately as much as we'd love to
Renewables cannot do it on their own
um but um hopefully with um sort of the
support of the fossil fuels and sort of
referring stuff mostly to gas which is
um still widely used and needed in our
economy
um we will be able to use those profits
to to invest into Renewables invest into
battery storage and help us uh get to to
that energy security and stability again
um the UK of course still incredibly
reliant on on gas as an energy source I
mean what could you see the government
in this country doing and of course we
do have a new government at the moment
at least a new prime minister what could
they be doing to to ramp up Renewables
as the the primary source of our energy
to take us away to take us to a point
where there is absolutely no need for
Reliance on fossils
so I think one of the biggest things
um that has to be done because
Renewables are intermittent so we we
can't guarantee or predict very well of
um how much um you know energy they're
gonna generate um over you know that
past uh one week for example
um but to solve that we need to heavily
invest in battery storage and hydrogen
um so anything that can change that you
know intermittent shape of Renewables
um is going to be the way forward to get
rid of the fossil fuels and move to The
Greener future
uh Christina rabbisita thanks very much
for joining us on the program
now hundreds of thousands of health
workers across England Wales and
Northern Ireland are voting on whether
to strike this winter over a payoffer
that's less than the rate of inflation
Unison members including nurses
paramedics midwives and Hospital staff
from more than 250 NHS trusts are being
balloted and I'm joined now on the
program by unison's Deputy head of
Health Helga Pike Helga lovely to have
you on the program this morning and just
explain uh the vote the ballot on strike
action what is it that your members need
so the moment the staff in the NHS have
had um a pay Award of just 72 Pence an
hour and that's just nowhere near enough
when they are struggling with the cost
of living crisis and they can't give
good care when they're going to work
hungry they're going home to cold cold
houses at the end of their long shifts
but equally it's about the Staffing
crisis that they're seeing day in day
out not enough staff in getting worse by
the day because colleagues are leaving
they can get better paid jobs and they
can have less stressful lives by going
elsewhere so this is about really trying
to use a vote about strike actions to
ask the government to listen and to look
at the facts and to see the 130 000
vacancies in England
and to understand that pay is a major
part of this Staffing crisis
um give us an idea of what it is like
then at the moment uh for those on the
front line particularly as we are seeing
those covered and flu infections
creeping up really dramatically
it's it's horrendous I mean if you just
if you look at every part of the system
whether it's ambulances queuing outside
hospitals some of our paramedics are
saying they're cute they're in in an
ambulance with a pet with a sick patient
for an entire shift because they can't
get the patient discharged it's it's
things like blood supplies we've just
heard are running low because there
aren't enough staff to run the blood
donor sessions
um it's Community star Community
Healthcare assistants and nurses who
whose patients are getting sicker by the
day because they're waiting for
treatment
um they're in that seven million weight
patient waiting list and these staff
don't want to leave their jobs they love
the work that they do but they do have
to pay their bills and all they've heard
so far from the government is well if
you get better paid jobs elsewhere then
that's what you should do and that's not
good enough because it's leaving
patients
um unsafe and staff feeling demoralized
and undervalued and as if the only
option they have is to consider strike
action
what happens Helga in those
circumstances we are talking about
hundreds of thousands of workers within
the Health Service if they were to go on
strike on Mass that would bring the
Health Service to its needs so what what
is the plan if the ballot goes uh
positive into in favor of strike action
well the first thing to say is Strike
action is not inevitable it really is in
in the hands of the Prime Minister the
and the latest team in health and in the
treasury to use the fact that this is
even happening as a wake-up call so
that's the first thing
staff wants to be able to say look we
need you to listen we need you to to
take this seriously so um voting in this
in this ballot is a way of trying to
create that that pressure and that jolt
to government that really this can't go
on so we really hope they listen to that
and that we don't have to take it
further and actually
um call people out on strike
we've gone through a couple of prime
ministers recently we've gone through a
couple of Health secretaries I wonder
what faith you have that Steve Barkley
might be the uh the man to actually
sought this situation out
well we've we've carefully uh written to
each Health secretary as they've come in
and we'll continue to do that and to try
to engage with Steve Barkley and um it's
interesting to note that the new
Chancellor was previously uh chair of
the health select committee and and he
described this as the biggest Workforce
crisis in the history of the NHS and we
know that pay is a major factor so let's
hope that now perhaps there's a slightly
more stable period ahead in terms of the
politics that they can actually turn
their attention to to the growing crisis
that's in front of them in the Health
Service
thanks so much for your time appreciate
it thank you
no the U.S midterm elections begin next
month a critical moment for the
Republicans is that they try to take
back control of Congress however the
senate race in Georgia has already been
smeared by accusations of hypocrisy as
the Republican hopeful Herschel Walker
faces claims for a second time of
encouraging and paying for a woman to
get an abortion a U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner reports
Herschel Walker is to his fans an
All-American hero an NFL star turned
politician now running to be senator in
his home state of Georgia I've been a
lot of places but in Wrightsville I
learned the important lessons he's
tapping into what's likely to be one of
the decisive issues of the upcoming
midterm elections the right to choose
abortion or not Georgia is a state that
respects life and I'll be a senator that
protects life
a man who on the face of it is
vehemently anti-abortion but is this a
Brazen display of political hypocrisy
because two women are now alleging they
became pregnant by Walker and that he
pressured them into having an abortion
the latest in listing a high-profile
lawyer Walker clearly wanted her to have
an abortion breaking her silence via a
conference call but not her anonymity
she says for fear of reprisals this Jane
Doe claims Walker drove her to a clinic
and paid for the procedure I was
devastated
because I felt that I had been pressured
into having an abortion
after the abortion
I felt that Herschel began distancing
himself from me
and this is a picture of Mr Walker Jane
Doe's legal team show me documents which
they say prove she is telling the truth
Love Letters From a six-year affair they
say a picture of Walker in a hotel room
and a receipt from a Holiday Inn do you
think this will have any effect on the
political race do you think voters in
Georgia care this is not just about the
values of virtual Whopper this is about
the values of every voter because if
they're voting for him then they are
expressing their values that it's okay
to lie
and it's okay
not to have your Deeds match your words
on the campaign Trail Walker issuing yet
another denial I'm done with this
foolishness I've already told people
this is a Lie the Republican party has
tied its hopes to Walker overcoming
another well-known face in his opponent
Reverend Rafael Warnock if it does win
it could be decisive in their fight to
gain control of Congress and despite the
Scandal this race is still neck and neck
Martha Kellner Sky News Los Angeles
welcome back Northern Ireland looks to
be heading for fresh elections a
midnight deadline is looming for a
devolved government to be formed and the
dup still refusing to restore
parachuting with Shin Fame at no sign of
a breakthrough therefore so a second
pull is expected to be called before
Christmas uh joining us now from Belfast
got to Claire rice an expert in
Devolution and power sharing at the
University of Liverpool Dr Rice great to
have you on the program this morning and
can you if possible if we possibly can
start by explaining why there has been
no functional government in Northern
Ireland for so long now
yes it's a it's quite a protracted story
so forgive me if I skim over some of the
details here
um essentially we um at the start of
February of this year we saw the
resignation of the first Minister here
in Northern Ireland who was from the
Democratic unionist party that was a
step that was taken in protest at the
Northern Ireland protocol which is the
aspect of the brexit arrangements for
each between the UK and the EU but
they're specifically with Northern
Ireland since then um we had an election
then in May of this year
um which somewhat changed the Dynamics
within the Northern Ireland assembly
um and since then there have been
several attempts to reconvene the
assembly so what's meant by that is
there have been a number of attempts to
nominate a speaker and their deputies to
make the Northern Ireland assembly
functional again
um so that has failed to happen and what
we're seeing happening today then is
another attempt to get the the assembly
back up and running again
um it's not expected that this location
will be any different to those that we
have seen
um so far but the added impetus here in
this occasion is that there is a
deadline that is approaching within a
matter of hours at this stage whereby if
there isn't an assembly back up and
running if an executive hasn't been
reformed then the Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland will be legally obliged
to call another election so we're
looking potentially at another election
Happening Here in Northern Ireland with
the the speculative debt at this stage
of the 15th of December I mean rather
begs the question if that deadline is
reached and breached does an election
sort anything out
um largely the the general prevailing
perspective and this is that no one
won't really change anything you might
see a bit of a redistribution of some of
the votes particularly around the dup
and the to UV the traditional unionist
voice party
um and there's some votes moving within
nationalism perhaps but by by and large
the Dynamics are going to remain the
same
um the only difference in this occasion
might be that if if there is an increase
in the vote share for the Democratic
unionist party they might be able to
take that or interpret that as leverage
for essentially having a mandate to
continue
um their position currently with regard
to the Northern Ireland protocol and to
continue a boycott of the institutions
so ultimately what an election would
later would be a hardening of the
possessions of the political parties
themselves what should make any talks or
negotiations between them much more
difficult and also making it um even
more difficult in in the aftermath uh to
to actually get things back up and going
again so essentially it could just end
up retracting the situation even further
um someone from that part of the world
admittedly in their cups but but someone
from that part of the world did suggest
to me at the weekend you know part of
the problem here is that the dup simply
do not want to be in a power sharing
arrangement with a Sinn Fein first
Minister I mean what's your view on that
assertion
um
The Experience on this there have been
some Whispers come and come within the
dep
uty
on these are going into a power sharing
arrangement with Shin fan warbai
Champaign has the first Minister
position in the dup word for the deputy
first Minister position but by the same
token that is a shared office
um so it isn't exactly accurate to say
that there would be a different type of
of on these in that relationship uh
going forward because it's a shared
office it would be a nominal uh
difference between the two so there's a
symbolic difference that has emerged as
a result of the last election in that
regard but I think by and large the
issue here isn't necessarily going into
Power sharing with Shinn Fein it is very
much the the position on the Northern
Ireland protocol it is very much the The
Wider issues that unionism as a whole is
feeling here in Northern Ireland that
have been exacerbated by brexit that
have been exacerbated by the impact of
the protocol
um and indeed the the difficult
relationship that we're seeing that's uh
between particularly the dup and the
conservative party in Westminster and
sorry to interrupt you there but we are
just out of time Dr Claire rice really
appreciate your time this morning
thank you
and as the new PM appears to backtrack
and Promises to Keep the triple lock on
pensions to stay where you are because
after this obviously you can Deliver Us
from shadowford David